bonjour nouveau numéro du café politique
sur tv fil 78 revue de presse de
l'actualité de ces quinze derniers jours
en compagnie d'élus du département et
pour nous accompagner au cours de cette
demi heure olivier paréja conseiller
europe écologie de saint quentin en iv
bienvenue vous êtes élu à guyancourt
dans la majorité
exactement peu la vue conseiller ps de
saint quentin dans l'opposition
également aux clayes-sous-bois voilà ce
que vous siégez en tant que conseiller
municipal et puis là jean baptiste
harmonique bonjour je vous êtes délégué
départemental et porte parole du modem
78 on va commencer par l'actualité
nationale et cette colère des policiers
qui s'exprime depuis plusieurs jours
vous avez forcément suivi dans
l'actualité léman déclencheur c'est
l'agression de cette patrouille en
mission de surveillance près d'un
carrefour connu notamment pour ses vols
avec violence sur les automobilistes à
proximité d'une cité c dans l'essonne un
dizaine de personnes cagoulées
selon les autorités qui ont brisé la
vitre de deux véhicules les ont
incendiées ont tenté de bloquer les
policiers à l'intérieur il ya une
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre à
travers toute la france pour la dénoncer
un peu ce aussi ce manque de moyens et
cet abandon parfois que peut ressentir
la police vous en tant que socialistes
et c'est avec vous je voulais commencer
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'échec malgré tout d'une politique
menée par le gouvernement en terme de
sécurité d'accompagnement de ces
policiers qui sont démunis aujourd'hui
et en plus on peut le dire au bout du
rouleau après tout les attentats qu'il a
fallu sur lesquels il a fallu intervenir
concernant
évidemment ce sujet là ce que cela
démontre malheureux malheureusement
c'est
lien qui se distend un petit peu plus et
qui s'est distendu depuis quelques
années entre les institutions et la
jeunesse une jeunesse un petit peu
marginalisé la jeunesse était
normalement la cible principale de ce
mandat pour lui hollande il en effet un
axe de campagne
et oui bien sûr sauf que moi ce que je
tiens quand même à rappeler malgré tout
c'est que sur la question la question
sécuritaire
il n'y avait eu il y avait mis en place
il ya quelques années de cela et je date
moins de 7 de ce remaniement
de cette époque le
lien qui se distend aujourd'hui entre
les institutions et les jeux et les
jeunes lorsque les socialistes
précisément avait mis en place
l'insécurité en proximité donc les
agents de proximité que le ministre de
l'intérieur en 2002 en 2000
2 évidemment à son arrivée à remise en
cause et à partir de ce moment là on a
senti évidemment que le lien ne pouvait
que se distendent entre l'institution et
les forces de sécurité
je ne suis pas forcément en train de
dédouaner l'ensemble de l'action du
gouvernement
mais je pense aussi qu'il faut aussi
partir d'un constat les d'un constat de
carence à certains moments lorsque la
droite était au pouvoir pendant dix ans
et qu'il a fallu rattraper ces dernières
années avec un budget qui évidemment
n'était pas aussi pléthorique que l'on
n'aurait pu
vouloir pour justement remettre en place
les moyens nécessaires
jean baptiste à monique vous en pensez
quoi de ce qui vient d'être dit là et
puis peut-être pour élargir un petit peu
mais on va est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui à des zones de non droit
en france
moi ça m'amène à de réflexion d'abord
sur le volet sécurité vous parler de
zones de non droit manuel valls le
premier ministre a dit que ce n'était
pas une zone de non-droit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut mettre les mots
sur les choses c'est une zone de
l'endroit il suffit de regarder les
portraits dans la presse qu'ils sont
vrais qu'ils sont dressés de de la
grande borne
quand vous avez des attaques à la
voiture-bélier quand vous avez des car
jacking quand vous avez des vols
récurrents
c'est une zone de non droit après il
faut regarder effectivement qu'on peut
faire alors il ya ce qu'on peut faire
dans l'immédiat donc c'est renforcer la
sécurité sur ces territoires territoires
qui sont oubliés de la république et qui
à mon sens sont à la fois l'échec de la
précédente majorité présidentielle et de
françois hollande aujourd'hui
concrètement il ya deux choses à faire
sur la sécurité je pense qu'il faut
renforcer les équipements des policiers
je sais que la région ile-de-france va
voter très rapidement une subvention
pour les pour l'équipement justement des
policiers de viry châtillon
on avait un tabou je pense aussi au tour
de l'armement de la police municipale je
pense que je sois aujourd'hui ce tabou
commencent à sauter sur l'armement de la
police municipale je pense que ça peut
être maintenant dans certains
territoires des solutions envisagées
pareil la vidéoprotection a longtemps
fait débat aujourd'hui il ya des élus de
gauche comme des élus de droite qui
commencent à mettre ces dispositifs en
oeuvre je pense que c'est essentiel est
la deuxième réflexion c'est c'est sur le
territoire faut vraiment regarder un peu
la spécificité de ce territoire
clairement ses 30 ans d'échec de
politique de la ville et d'urbanisation
de ce quartier là après moi je veux pas
content dans les petites phrases
j'entends aussi certaines personnes de
l'opposition actuellement qui disent
voilà il faut que bernard cazeneuve
démissionne c'est je pense pas que ce
soit la solution
comme je disais aujourd'hui faut mettre
faut mettre des mots sur les situations
qu'on parle d'un grenelle de la sécurité
intérieure en tout cas c'est ce que
demande le secrétaire général
d'un syndicat de police oui très bien
alors après tout voilà feu juste pas que
ça reste au stade des bonnes intentions
fauqué du concret derrière soi les
habitants semblent le sentiment d'être
d'être abandonnés ont ils se méfient
sont totalement il ya aussi la question
des services publics locaux
je veux dire il ya la poste qui a fermé
dans ce territoire là il ya plus de
médecins généralistes même sos médecins
ne va plus dans ce quartier là de peur
de se faire de se faire caillasser donc
il ya une vraie question à l'abandon il
ya un abandon total est donc aujourd'hui
je pense que les deux choses
essentielles c'est faire à nouveau
appliquer les lois de la république
dans ce territoire et prendre en compte
les habitants qui veut pour le coup sont
de vrais oubliés de la république
olivier paréja on a entendu parler
d'armement de la police municipale vous
qui siégeait dans la majorité à
guyancourt par exemple alors je pense
pas que ça soit le jour de la nuit en
cours mais enfin moi ce que je voudrais
redire c'est que la police en
particulier la police nationale c'est un
service public donc il est absolument
logique de le défendre et que les
fonctionnaires soient protégés ça paraît
ça paraît une évidence mais à linverse
faut peut-être pas non plus aller
complètement dans l'excès je pense que
en ce moment on a aussi le modèle de ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis où la police
est surarmé où il ya des bavures en
permanence en particulier à l'encontre
des minorités et il faut surtout pas que
on tombe en france dans ce genre de
dérives et donc les jours enfin je
trouve que l'on devrait aussi mettre les
actes et les et les paroles en cohérence
quand on dit une paye de l' urbanisation
on paye des erreurs qui ont été faites
puis pluie des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années en créant des ghettos en créant
des choses comme ça mais à ce moment là
pourquoi dans les yvelines
le conseil départemental décide de
réduire les crédits de la prévention
spécialisée donc des éducateurs de rue
qui sont dans la prévention là on n'est
pas dans le curatif est de la partie
comment les policiers vont se défendre
mais dans la prévention à long terme
hélas les budgets sont réduits là il ya
une réorganisation dont on n'a pas
encore complètement compris le
fonctionnement
donc il faut peut-être aussi mettre les
paroles en fonction les actes pardon en
face d'arles
du territoire je ne faisais pas
référence à 50 allant l'occurrence je
faisais vraiment référence voilà sur le
cas de l'essonne bien sûr l'armement de
la police municipale c'est pas quelque
chose qui coule de source on va dire
pour pour toutes les communes c'est ça
dépend vraiment des 50 ans des communes
se pose la question parce que
l'opposition a demandé soit réglé parce
que ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un moyen de
protéger et nos forces de l'ordre et nos
concitoyens donc il faut pas il faut pas
rejeter l'idée par idéologie ou voilà
mais je ne suis pas sûr que la police de
proximité dont on parlait tout à l'heure
ça soit la police municipale il faut il
faut que ces gens se voir poser et moi
je regrette quand même que démanteler
depuis 2003 je suis désolé mais la
police municipale elle a pas été remises
en place pendant le diplôme le
quinquennat et au contraire monde à cela
la police de proximité pardon la police
de proximité n'a pas été remis en place
pendant ce quinquennat c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut regretter et al'inverse
les répression policière qui a eu aussi
bien pendant la loi travaille que
pendant un certain nombre de sujets qui
me touchent à coeur que ce soit le
barrage de siemens où on est allé
jusqu'à un mort etc
c'est aussi une responsabilité politique
de mettre la police nationale dans un
affrontement avec la population qui
n'est pas de nature à apaiser les
tensions et un moment faut aussi que
l'on reste cohérente sur ces sujets là
on va avancer un peu cette revue de
presse et changer de sujet c'est
principe d'une revue de presse un sujet
qui concerne le pays mais aussi le
département saint quentin en yvelines
c'est paris 2024 paris candidate avec
une forte implication des yvelines de
saint quentin en yvelines plusieurs
sites la colline d'elancourt par exemple
golf national à saint quentin le
vélodrome aussi à montigny seulement
pour décrocher la compétition il faut
mettre la main à la poche le département
va par exemple voter le financement des
aménagements sur la colline d'elle en
cours alors que les impôts locaux aussi
ont augmenté fortement cette année parce
que parlais tout à l'heure des
diminutions qui ont été faites sur
certains dossiers par le département
mais il faut aussi faire des économies
vous parlez de la baisse des dotations
des dotations il faut faire des
économies
donc là pour en revenir à paris de 1024
est organisé les jeux c'est une bonne
chose est ce que ce ne va pas coûter
trop cher
vous pouvez question
alors je me suis déjà exprimé au conseil
communautaire sur le sujet plusieurs
fois s'est engagé aussi fine pour nous
on en parle on en sort on parle de l'est
tout ce qu'il faudrait faire en terme de
social en termes de polices etc et on va
dépenser des milliards pour des jeux
olympiques les jeux olympiques tels
qu'ils existent aujourd'hui on est quand
même très loin de la charte olympique de
l'image de paix la guerre en syrie a
continué pendant les jeux olympiques
enfin et on n'est pas dans la pratique
du sport amateur pour tout le monde donc
on est vraiment dans une une
commercialisation des jeux qui est qui
et quand même regrettable et pour ce
faire on va dépenser des milliards rien
que la candidature de paris va coûter
entre 60 et 100 millions rien que pour
faire acte de candidature selon le tibet
des participations de l'état c'est plus
d'un milliard alors là aussi ça va être
un milliard maintenant mais les jeux de
tokyo
les jeux de londres les jeux de tokyo et
on est déjà alors qu'ils n'ont pas eu
lieu on est déjà à plus de 4 milliards
de dépassement du budget est dans les
chiffres je danse banques pékin en 2008
c'était 2 6 milliards annoncés je
revérifie ce que j'ai bien écrit il n'y
a pas de coquille ses 32 milliards au
fil de l'eau mais oui à d'emblée
sollicité totalement ridicule donc on
nous dit on nous dit bien sûr en france
on va n'est pas dépassée on est plus
malin que tout le monde mais tous les
jeux précédents ont largement dépassé
leur budget est ce que c'est la priorité
aujourd'hui si je peux me permettre
distinguer deux choses
effectivement les avis des uns c'est un
milliard et 105 millions en fait là un
milliard de l'état et 500 millions qui
seront portés par le restant des
collectivités il est la grande partie
c'est du film de la primaire
c'est faut pas oublier ça donc c'est pas
à la charge de la collectivité
moi je les vois une opportunité majeure
pour le développement du territoire
le territoire francilien et notamment
les yvelines concrètement je pense que
ça va être un coup de boost sur des
grands projets d'infrastructures et des
chantiers notamment en termes de
transport je pense à la ligne 18
notamment et en termes de développement
économique de rayonnement du territoire
en plus on sait comment se porte
aujourd'hui le secteur du tourisme
c'est une réussite une réelle chance je
pense qu'on a nos territoires après
effectivement ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est beaucoup final le coût final de ce
que cela va apporter et comparer ça avec
les retombées économiques qui seront
faites en fait sur sur les yvelines et
sur l'île de france mais bon moi je
crois je pense que fufu regarder après
ce qui s'est passé sur sur les villes
qui organisait les genoux auparavant moi
je vois ce qui est devenu barcelone je
vois ce qui est devenu londres
clairement les jo ont été une chance
pour pour pour le dynamisme de ces
villes là donc puis sur la france et en
ce qui concerne exactement année mais il
ya des fois où il ya des structures qui
existent déjà exactement ça c'est qu'il
ya des offres le golfe qui sera après
puisque 2018 la ryder cup donc le golf
national devra accueillir la compétition
sur sefyu souvient de la ville où a eu
lieu les compétitions de cyclisme ou les
compétitions de golf sur les sur les
gigots précédent on se souvient de on se
souvient de pékin ont souri le blond
elle qui draine beaucoup et donc on se
souviendra de paris on ne se souviendra
pas de saint quentin en yvelines c'est à
l'heure c'est un lieu où je n'ai pas
forcément de se rappeler de 50 ans vous
ne sera plus dans la communauté
d'agglomération investi des centaines de
milliers d'euros jeudi pas des millions
là ça risque d'être plutôt elles sont l
ultime
le se poser la question où la chance que
nous avons malgré tout c'est d'avoir
quelques sites qui existe déjà puisque
évidemment nous avons déjà visé des
sites il ya quelques années lorsque
paris s'était porté candidat pour les
précédentes pour la précédente
précédentes olympiades
donc il ya quelques sites qui existent
déjà nous avons la chance évidemment
d'en avoir quelques-uns sur saint
quentin en yvelines
il y a il ya le stade de france qui
existe qui va être peut-être un petit
peu configurer enfin bon il ya quelques
sites qui existent
et pour le coup je pense que en termes
de coûts alors oui il ya un milliard
d'annoncé ou peut peut-être
dépassés peut-être que ce geste sera
dépassée ou non mais en tout cas il sera
déjà un peu plus contraints que dans
d'autres communes enfin d'autres
d'autres pays et d'autres comme une
capitale qui ont porté les jeux puisque
nous avons déjà des structures
existantes
après moi ce que nous fallait un double
un double sentiment sur sur ce sujet là
parce qu'évidemment je trouve toujours
intéressant qu'il ya des événements un
petit peu fondateur enfin pas fondateur
mais marquant pour une population qui
permettent de créer du cimo et du lien
ce que je souhaitais que j'espère de
cette candidature c'est qu'elle puisse
justement créer du lien par exemple au
sein de la région de l'euro par exemple
on avait été un très bon exemple en
france on l'a vu même avec les
communautés issues d'autres pays qui qui
qui arrive est évidemment au sein du
pays a été accueilli par leur communauté
et du coup des liens étaient à partir
des gisements métissée marc était très
intéressant par contre évidemment
de l'autre côté il faut que cette
candidature et donc les coûts inhérents
à cette candidature et les dépenses qui
seront liées sont aussi utiles
socialement comme le rappelait le sua
monique va un moment donné il faut aussi
que tout ce qui sera apportée mais ce
qui sera créé à cette occasion là soient
utiles socialement pour le pays dans
l'avenir
que ce soit au niveau des transports que
ce soit au niveau des logements qu'elle
soit au niveau des conditions de
circulation
il faut évidemment que tout cela est un
rebond et qu'on puisse en bénéficier que
les franciliens puissent en bénéficier
à l'issue de ces jeux juste un peu
rajouté chaussée d'accord je pense qu'on
a besoin d'engouement populaire donc
autour de ce manifestant sur lie l'euro
était un bon exemple
et puis faut pas oublier que pendant un
peu moins d'un mois la france venait
enfin paris en tout cas il a rejoint de
france va être la vitrine du monde et ça
va être l'occasion un peu de redorer
notre blason suite à ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement donc cette histoire sort le
13 septembre ses services et ainsi si
paris est finalement retenue juste deux
jours quand même rome hambourg récemment
je sais plus boston ont quand même
décliné leur candidature je veux dire le
raisonnement n'est pas aussi simple que
de dire que ça va être favorable et je
voudrais juste revenir sur le vélodrome
certes on a la chance de la voix mais
coûte quand même 4,7 millions d'euros
pendant 27 ans à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
donc c'est quand même pas grave vous
faut le rentabiliser maintenant il faut
mais comme le disait mais comme le dit
monsieur la chance qu'on a c'est
effectivement qu'il ya énormément
d'infrastructure qui sont déjà
existantes donc c'est pas une
candidature totalement fantaisiste mais
du tout fantaisistes et je pense qu'elle
a toutes ses chances d'aboutir et on
verra ça donc le 13 septembre 2010 est
avant que vous demandez ce que vous
retenez de l'actualité de ces quinze
derniers jours juste j'aimerais avoir
votre sentiment sur le départ dans des
élus du département de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est le maire socialiste de guyancourt
françois de ligne et qui vient
d'annoncer sa démission il était en
poste depuis 2002 il va rester
conseiller municipal et puis également
conseiller communautaire à saint quentin
en yvelines mais il souhaite passer la
main au / déjà vous avez forcément
regard particulier parce que vous siégez
dans la majorité de cette commune à
guyancourt
mais au-delà de ça après j'aimerais
aussi vous entendre sur le sur le choix
de ces mères de ses élus qui passent la
main en cours de mandat et qui disent
préparer l'avenir est ce qu'on ne vole
pas d'une certaine manière le scrutin
en trahissant de moi peut-être fort la
volonté des électeurs olivier paréja
tout d'abord votre regard sur ce départ
de françois de ligne et alors ce départ
ils étaient plus ou moins déjà annoncé
des dons qui l'avait annoncé il avait
annoncé qu'il passerait la main donc
après on peut se demander si c'est pas
un petit peu tôt enfin je le dit et j'en
ai parlé avec lui donc
mais il ya un paradoxe c'est que à la
fois on peut critiquer le système
français parce que il est très présente
présidentialiser au niveau national et
dans une commune c'est la même chose
tout tourne autour du maire est par
exemple les adjoints ont des délégations
du maire donc tout tourne autour du même
et puis après le but c'est quand même
qu'ils aient une équipe mais qu'il n'y
ait pas une seule personne même si sous
le système tend à vocaliser s'est brisé
au moment du vote on vote pour une liste
qui portait pas vraiment bien évidemment
ce ne sont pas les électeurs direct
voilà qui font le maire puisqu'ensuite
s'est décidée en conseil municipal
est ce que tout le monde le sait pas
forcément mais effectivement et on a
aussi une responsabilité c'est que dans
les élections on le présente pas non
plus comme ça c'est à dire que on vote
pour françois de ligné et son équipe
alors que s'il y avait dès le début
plusieurs personnes qui s'engagent en
disant ben moi je serai en charge de
tels secteurs et j'ai l'intention de
faire ça moi je suis en charge de tels
secteurs j'ai l'intention de faire ça
dans l'équipe si on présentait comme une
équipe
ce changement passerait mieux auprès des
électeurs qui je suis d'accord ne
doivent pas nécessairement comprendre
l'impression d'avoir voté pour quelqu'un
qui part au bout de deux ans et demi
alors que quelque part
structurellement on a voté pour une
équipe mais bon je pense que dans notre
communication mais raison de passer la
main en tout cas après celle de ses dix
ans plus tôt c'est une c'est une façon
de préparer de préparer la suite je
pense que tout le monde le fait plus ou
moins d'un an il ya beaucoup de communes
où ça serait comme ça c'est déjà fait je
voudrais déjà salué l'action de françois
de ligné
pour les gluants courtois alors je ne
suis pas gluant courtois mais j'ai suivi
évidemment assez régulièrement la
politique mise en place par par le maire
et son équipe tu as raison puisque
évidemment fin
une équipe municipale on vote pour elle
et non pour son maire et il est
important justement de replacer à chaque
fois cette notion dans le contexte de
politique locale général puisque
évidemment tout le monde à un moment
donné peut avoir comme dira son mot à
dire et son action à mener au sein d'une
équipe municipale
donc évidemment salué l'action de
françoise sur survie en cours et sur
saint quentin en yvelines et ça lui
aussi son geste parce que j'entends dire
que c'est trop tôt extérieures extrêmes
et beaucoup font cette démarche là un an
à peine un an et demi avant les
élections suivantes
histoire de préparer la main mais de ne
pas non plus
il faut de dire de certains de griller
son poulain et moi ce que je trouve
vraiment intéressant pour le coup c'est
que là
françois parent avec une avec une
volonté justement de transmettre le
relais et de préparer l'avenir
précisément et l'avenir ne se prépare
pas un avant les élections municipales
il se prépare bien en amont avec une
équipe et en mettant en avant les
principaux intervenants au sein de cette
équipe et je trouve que pour le coup 7,7
cette démarche est intéressante françois
être telus je crois depuis 12 ans à peu
près il me semble mais depuis en tant
que maire de depuis depuis 12 ans
bientôt 14 ans et du coup se pose aussi
et se remet aussi en perspective
à l'issue un vin à l'occasion de cette
de cette démission
la question du rhône fin du cumul des
mandats et du cumul des mandats dans le
temps et je pense que il est peut-être
aussi intéressant on voit là françois de
ligne et partir au bout de 14 ans
presque deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
de mandat et on peut aussi se dire que
nous avons
travailler sur le cumul des mandats en
nombre et que cette démission peuvent
aussi nous amener à réfléchir sur une
législation un petit peu plus large en
termes de cumul des mandats et sur le
non renouvellement du cumul des mandats
dans le temps
jean baptiste à monique rapidement à ce
qu'après le temps pour faire faire sur
le cumul des mandats dans le temps je
suis totalement d'accord c'est un thème
qu'on porte au modem depuis depuis assez
longtemps après moi il ya une petite
phrase qui m'a fait sourire je sais plus
si c'était dans les nouvelles ou dans le
parisien c'est de dire qu'on que par
cette démission ou participer au
renouvellement de la classe politique
dont je rappelle juste que sa première
adjointe à 60 ans et 60 ans et le
renouvellement c'est dommage pour s'en
remettre du tout en cause les
compétences de sa première base doit pas
faire dans le jeunisme non plus mais le
renouvellement de la classe politique
n'est pas forcément je suis d'accord
mais pas forcément une question d'âge
mais aussi une question de pratiquer une
question de
de mise en perspective d'une nouvelle de
nouvelles propositions de nouveaux
développements de projets à partir de
nouvelles nouvel exécutif qui sera
vraiment dans la lignée de ce qui a été
déjà fait normalement à quoi joue pas
aux vieux qui sont je vais vous poser
sur les quinze derniers jours
olivet paréja sur les gens qu'est ce que
moi j'aimerais revenir sur un sujet qui
peut ne pas paraître locale mais qu'elle
est traitée transatlantique pour
lesquels la ville de manille la verrière
guyancourt ont décidé de de se mettre
hors traité transatlantique et on est en
train on est sur le point de ratifier un
traité avec le canada qui est exactement
dans la même lignée et ça va avoir un
impact local sur les marchés publics par
exemple sur des régies municipales ça
peut être pour les transports ça peut
être pour pour la restauration etc
est ce ce type de deux traités pour
lequel le gouvernement vient enfin de
dire qu'il était contre pour le traité
transatlantique on va être signé pro va
ratifier probablement prochainement un
traité avec le canada qui est tout aussi
dangereux pour notre fonctionnement
démocratique locale et je trouve que ça
passe un peu inaperçu et c'est ce que
j'aurais aimé souligné voilà deux
questions c'est rapide qui ont retenu
mon attention ces derniers jours
évidemment la question du traitement des
réfugiés et des migrants dans notre
notre pays et ça aussi un impact local
puisque nous avons vécu des
des scènes de manifestations assez je
qualifie d' assez ubuesque dans notre
secteur et la deuxième chose est
évidemment la question de
du recours massif à l'impôt
de la part du département qui dans le
même temps n'a pas hésité à supprimer
nombre de service que ce soit dans la
culture que ce soit dans prévention
spécialisée que ce soit dans la petite
enfance avec l'arrêt des subventions aux
crèches et aux nombres de berceau au
berceau dans ses crèches est évidemment
mis à 7 mètres sont saturés de la
notation rappelle l'état à quillan moins
d'argent et les dépenses sociales qui
augmentent parce que les dépenses voulu
des parfums dans l'obligation de luzon
vers des dépenses sociales plus en fin
de ces baisses sont connus sont à son
vécu de la part des collectivités depuis
en tout cas une stagnation de la zone
vouloir défendre le département lieu-dit
la baisse est de 50 années 90 %
c'est-à-dire compris qu'ils imaginent
une baisse depuis 2000 13,2 de cette
baisse de cette dotation est donc de ce
fonds de péréquation et
un an après les élections personne aucun
des élus ne nous a prévenus et n'a
prévenu les électeurs de ce qui allait
se tramer sur le budget 2016 et donc de
la disparition de certains services
alors que tout cela était connu de la
part des élus et de l'équipe qui gérait
le conseil départemental depuis quatre
ans déjà juste qui pourrait agir très
rapidement sur les traités sans
transatlantique je suis assez d'accord
je pense que aujourd'hui ça a été ça a
été négocié dans une opacité mais
terrible donc c'est assez difficile de
se prononcer sur le contenu même de ces
traités parce que voilà on sait qu'il ya
un danger potentiel
aujourd'hui on n'en sait pas plus sur
bon sur les coupures au niveau du
département il ya la baisse des
dotations je vais pas revenir dessus et
ils ont été notifiés assez tard ils ont
connu le montant très tardivement de ce
que justement il allait il allait perdre
nous le sujet aussi effectivement que
j'avais choisi c'était aussi celui de
l'accueil des réfugiés et des demandeurs
d'asile je préfère d'ailleurs ce terme à
celui de migrant concrètement j'ai été
aussi choqué de la réaction de certains
élus du département et même de députés
du département nous aujourd'hui on
appelle à ce que cette question soit
soient traités avec humanité et
pragmatisme
concrètement aujourd'hui ces quelques
centaines ces quelques centaines de
migrants qui sont déjà installés qui
sont dans des noues lendemain de
réfugiés demandeurs d'asile qui sont
actuellement sur sur paris en fait c'est
pas s'ils viennent pas de calais cela me
sont ils sont dans des camps c'est bien
vivre dans des conditions indignes à
paris donc il suffit de le retrouver
quelques places je pense que si on se
met autour de la table avec les élus
locaux le préfet et l'état et j'appelle
l'état aussi à prendre ses
responsabilités sur cette question on va
trouver des solutions
alors je prêche un peu pour ma paroisse
mais si vous avez l'occasion d'aller
voir ce qui se passe à pau chez françois
bayrou il a accueilli plusieurs
centaines de familles de migrants et il
les a pas mis dans des camps et les rp
dissimulées partout sur le territoire on
est vraiment les intégrant dans le reste
des quartiers de pau donc voilà il faut
il faut vraiment traiter cette question
là
en bonne intelligence et arrêter de
lever les levées de boucliers en
expliquant qu' il arrive là pour les
prestations sociales non aujourd'hui
c'est des gens qui fuient
effectivement la guerre chez eux et
voilà ce qui ce qui leur importe c'est
de survivre tout simplement et le
dernier point parce que c'est l'européen
convaincu la qui parle je pense que
cette question ne fasse soit la
problématique va perdurer tant que temps
que l'europe ne se sera pas décidée à
agir de concert sur cette problématique
merci avec trois ans la lead et de
répartir de pas faire des concentrations
de dizaines de milliers de migrants au
même endroit c'est nécessairement la
solution également plusieurs endroits
c'est évident et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci à tous les trois en tout cas
le mot de la fin pour pour cette
émission peut toujours poursuivre la
conversation ensuite on se retrouve très
bientôt au bistrot du théâtre à montigny
pour une nouvelle édition du café
politique merci encore merci